TO HEAR FROM MANY OTHER SHOWS.
I JUST APPRECIATE YOUR BEING
WITH US.
GOD BLESS YOU AND YOUR FAMILY.
I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT ALL OF THIS
IS FOR YOU.
I WANT TO GO TO THE CONGRESSMAN
NOW.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US BECAUSE NOT A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS DECIDE TO COME ON FOX,
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
COMING ON TO SHARE YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS ISSUE.
I REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT.
AND CONGRESSMAN, TODD ROKITA,
OBVIOUSLY, YOU HAVE BEEN DEALING
WITH THE AFTERMATH OF A VERY
POPULAR NFL STAR WHO WAS KILLED
IN A DRUNK DRIVING ACCIDENT.
SO YOU HEAR THE ANGUISH OF A
PAM, WHOSE NEPHEW WAS A
PHENOMENAL HUMAN BEING.
AND HE WAS KILLED A FEW YEARS
AGO BY AN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT.
JUST A SENTENCE A FEW DAYS AGO.
WHAT DO YOU SAY AFTER HEARING
THAT ANGUISH IN HER VOICE?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I MEAN, I
CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT SHE IS GOING
THROUGH.
I’VE GOT THREE BROTHERS WHO ARE
PEACE OFFICERS.
IN FACT, ONE OF THEM WAS AN
UNDERCOVER NARCOTICS OFFICER AND
BECAME A LIEUTENANT IN CHARGE OF
THAT.
SO RIGHT NOW HE IS A BORDER
SHERIFF, SO I KNOW WHAT IT IS TO
HAVE BROTHERS THAT ARE PEACE
OFFICERS AND NOT KNOW WHAT COULD
HAPPEN FROM ONE DAY TO THE NEXT.
SO I UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS TO
HAVE THREE FAMILY MEMBERS THAT
ARE PEACE OFFICERS, AND AGAIN,
TO ME, IT IS A MEMBER OF THAT
PERSON WHO KILLED THAT PEACE
OFFICER, IT IS DOCUMENTED OR
UNDOCUMENTED, OR WHOEVER GOES
AFTER A PEACE OFFICER, WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE THROW THE
BOOK OUT THAT INDIVIDUAL.
>> Laura: YET, BUT OBVIOUSLY,
IT MAKES IT WORSE, DOES IT NOT,
AND CONGRESSMAN ROKITA, WE
WILL GET TO YOU, BUT HE
OBVIOUSLY SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
IN THE COUNTRY.
OTHERWISE THEY WOULD STILL BE
ALIVE.
THAT IS WHAT MAKES IT WORSE, AND
I KNOW CONGRESS IS WORKING ON A
BELT AND A PUSH FOR
LEGALIZATION, AND SOME MORE
ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS, CHANGING
THE IMMIGRATION, BUT I’VE GOT TO
TELL YOU.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE FED UP WITH
THIS CRIME, AND THIS HAS GOT TO
STOP.
THIS IS MADNESS.
>> LAURA, IF I COULD JUMP IN, I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT THIS IS
COMPLETELY PREVENTABLE, HAD WE
HAD A WALL, HAD WE HAD A WALL
SYSTEM, HAD WE BEEN ENFORCING
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION LAW, WHAT